Am I in love with my husband of four years?
Before my husband and I got engaged,
we had a courtship with very strict physical boundaries
that we set in the place.
We tried very hard to keep our emotions
and romance out of it
so that we can get to know each other
logically and deeply
without overlooking anything in infatuation.
Because of this,
y'all are wondering,
did we fall in love?
Do we have a romantic relationship now?
Is it. Or is it more of a partnership?
Well, it was a good thing we didn't touch
until we got engaged,
because we found out the physical touch
is both of our primary love languages.
Couple months before we got engaged,
I knew that I was definitely growing to love Andrew.
Signs of infatuation were cropping up.
He gave me butterflies.
I was nervous around him.
I couldn't hardly spend enough time with him,
which was difficult
being long distance.
I was hanging on to his every word.
Saying yes to marry him was the easiest
and the most anticipated question I have ever answered.
We immediately fell into our first tug.
And considering how we're still attached at the hip,
I don't think we ever broke that.
Now, four years later,
we're still called the lovebirds.
We're each other's best friends,
and if we're in the same room,
we're probably touching somehow.
But most importantly,
I believe that we have a love that transcends feelings.
A love that We show every day by actions and words.
Even when it's been a long day
or were stressed
or not feeling the butterflies at that moment.
We put each other first
and we sacrifice for the others well being.
And that, my friends, is love.